willkommen in meiner neuen wohnung
ich bin vor ein paar tagen umgezogen und
schlafe zwar immer noch zwischen
umzugskartons nicht mehr mein pcs
angeschlossen
dafür ist meine küche aber schon fast
fertig und ich dachte mir nach zwei
jahren kochbücher schreiben koch videos
drehen torten dekorieren ist es mal an
der zeit dass ich euch zeige was ich
denn so alles habe so ein bisschen
küchen flags inc
und wie ich lese ein negatives
kommentare mikrofon in meiner hand es
ist halt noch eine leere wohnung und
eine leere wohnung halten weil ich das
normale mikrofon benutzen würde dann
würde es so klingen
also spreche ich lieber ins mikrofon
wenn man so eine neue küche hat muss man
sie natürlich erst mal mit der
standardausrüstung einrichten und es ist
so eine lebenswichtige entscheidung wo
du deine teller hin packt und gläsern
tas nicht meinen du wirst ja die
nächsten jahre aus diesem ort holen und
der ort muss gut ausgewählt sein
deswegen hab ich mal erst mal ein paar
duftkerze hingestellt und das chakra
dieser küche herauskristallisiert um den
perfekten platz für meine teller zu
finden
wow also willkommen in der küche hier
wir haben ein buch in der sich eintreten
kann
und hier befinden sich dann auf alle
schränke und fangen mit den tellern und
die befinden sich hier zusammen mit in
tiefen tellern und schüsseln habe ich
auch ganz viele also seit dem kochbuch
mal wieder hunderte chinesen brauchen ja
habe ich in allen farben und formen
schüsseln die heute noch große schüsseln
kleine teller auf das sind in italien
ich wusste gleich dass es geht wenn ich
wütend bin mir nicht sicher ob ich den
perfekten platz gefunden habe aber ich
bin ganz zufrieden mit der aufteilung
dann gibt es vier unter dem herbst also
meinen ganzen lesern in stroheim plastik
ist ja böse
[Musik]
deswegen wurde ich gehe sondern
strohhalme ich verlinke die woher ich
nie hab hier habe ich mich die ganze
zitieren weil ich auf asiatisches essen
stehe
und ja
kann ich nur mit ess stäbchen essen weil
sie uns einfach dass ich ruhiger sonst
was haben wir hier noch york papier
mülltüten plastik ist böse aber manchmal
muss man auch was einpacken
hier haben wir noch so kleinkram und da
habe ich so eine matte von ikea gekauft
weil ich das in der alten küche hatte
ich noch so schubladen
die folge mit waren mit diesen ganzen
kram halt also peter schneider crêpes
ich habe wirklich ich habe es so viel
zeug ein selbst drehender teller mit 5
km h und selbstreinigungsfunktion schau
dort an dieser stelle für diese geniale
matte diesmal life balance müssen sich
ein café halten würde
ich bin schon ein bisschen aufgeregt ist
meine neue kirche ihr werdet ab sofort
nur noch koch videos aus dieser kirche
sehen das nächste wird natürlich wieder
einen drei cocktails die ball an also
mit kochen ist schon lange nichts mehr
auf diesem kanal
aber ich verspreche euch in 2009 10 wird
das koch thema wieder richtig
ausgelutscht und ich habe so gute ideen
und so gute pläne und mein kochbuch
kommt auch bald und dann beginnt erst
die richtige promo phase dann das ist
richtig hardcore kochen angesagt hier
auf diesem kanal dankeschön jetzt meine
damen und herren ist es zeit für eine
kurze werbeunterbrechung
ich liebe lesen aber manche geschichten
die kann man sich nur anschauen
toll mit dem neuen sky entertainment
ticketangebot kann ich jetzt bis ende
märz für vier euro 99 den zweiten teil
der neunten staffel the walking dead
schauen super und wenn man schnell ist
dann bekommt man doch den rest des
februars geschenk und man kann sich alle
tollen serie mit dem sky entertainment
ticket anschauen denn es gibt da noch so
viel weitere highlights heißt man
bezahlt 50 prozent des originalpreises
ist es sogar günstiger als ein buch und
dazu noch monatlich kündbar und ich kann
es nicht nur mit dem laptop schauen
sondern auch mit dem smart tvs meiner
ps4 dem handy und und und also klickt
jetzt schnell auf den ersten link in der
beschreibung und holt euch das sky
entertainment ticket für vier euro 99
bis ende märz
klasse ich jetzt noch weiter schauen
bis dann kommen wir zu den gewürzen und
lebensmittel in einer küche meiner küche
ihr johnson
ich muss ehrlich sagen ich bin so froh
dass ich endlich umgezogen bin weil
meine alte küche schon ganz cool war und
ich weiß viele von euch haben mir
geschrieben du wohnst du doch erst seit
einem jahr was los ich habe gemerkt dass
da irgendwie die aufteilung von den
tränken und so doch nicht so optimal ist
vor allem die lebensmittel und gewürze
die habe ich zum ende sind nur noch in
irgendwelchen ecken gefeuert weil da hat
einfach kein platz war und mein gewürz
schrank da habe ich eh nichts mehr
durchgeblickt und jetzt habe ich halt so
eine schublade
die kann ich auch machen und dann sehe
ich halt alles sofort was ich habe und
mir ist aufgefallen dass sich sehr viele
gewürze habe ich koche jetzt nicht so
kreativ dass ich so viele benutzer aber
es sammelt sich halt an
und fürs kochbuch vor allem und für
andere dinge hat
da braucht man dann halt einfach mal
wacholderbeeren die brauchst du dann
einmal wenn dubios machst und dann sind
sie da und du willst sie nicht
wegschmeißen weil es kann ja mal sein
dass du in einem jahr wieder groß machen
willst
das system ist hier noch nicht ganz
durch gedacht aber ich habe auf jeden
fall drei gläser honig weil ich jeden
tag ein erdbeer marmelade und mit honig
es ist doch klar hier sind die wir
kontaktieren verschmoren wildgerichte
kurkuma 1 mittlerweile eines meiner
lieblings gewürze geworden weil es auch
alles so schön gelb macht also wenn ihr
zum beispiel gelben reis haben wollt
kurkuma ich weiß nicht warum im gelben
kreis haben wollt aber ja der mich schon
ein bisschen länger kennt weil oft
pumpkins ball klasse und jetzt hab ich
pumpkins preis gekauft weiß ja auch für
latte macchiato ausgemacht sind die
haben wir auch tabak und soja passierte
tomaten also alles was so ein bisschen
standard zu hause sein sollte
und solche sachen wie nudeln und reis
und zu anderen alltäglichen kram
den habe ich auch versucht
unterzubringen da bin ich aber froh dass
diese wohnung eine abstellkammer hat in
der ich halt auch lebensmittel lagern
kann denn über so ein paar torten videos
und anderen bug videos haben sich als 20
packung mehl angesammelt ja ich weiß ich
bin ein schlechter mensch habe 20
packung mehl gehabt die habe ich alle
zusammen gekippt jetzt habe ich glaube
ich noch hier
ich habe mir auf jeden fall für dieses
jahr gemerkt dass ich mal öfter in
meinen schrank rhein gucken was ist denn
überhaupt noch so an
da haben denn nach 20 packen mail weißt
du dass du ein problem hast es ist nur
bei den ahs anonym
lebensmittel horta narrhalla
ich kann jetzt endlich meine ganzen back
artikel ordentlich erstaunen ich habe
halt nicht nur 20 mio packungen sondern
auch 360 verschiedene lebensmittel
farben und irgendwelche backpulver typen
panels sogar töten weil ich in der alten
wohnung hat das immer irgendwelche
schubladen reingestopft habe und nie so
ein ordentlich gesammelten punkt hatte
wo ich sage ich möchte etwas backen ja
klar
dann gehe ich jetzt mal in meine idee da
rein und dann hole ich mir das was ich
brauche und jetzt habe ich eine schöne
kiste in dieses einsortieren können
lebensmittel in dreifach aus
mit dem fahrrad einen blick wir hatten
wir lebensmittelfarbe lebensmittel
fahren aber das war vielleicht das
nämlich so in die abstellkammer
reinpacken und dann wenn ich irgendwas
brauche kann ich mir die ganze klasse
mitnehmen oder weder halt alles ein
schritt und das ist nicht die ganze zeit
in der küche weil wer braucht tagtäglich
und mit so einem tollen kisten system da
bekommt man wieder richtig bock zum
backen bock zum backen und jetzt ist
eine zeit dass ich auch mal flexen kann
mit meinen küchengeräte
ich habe viele küchengeräte die meisten
benutze ich auch nur einmal im jahr oder
so aber trotzdem nice to have nice to
have da wäre zum beispiel meine
kitchenaid dieses baby kind merkt ihr
euch meine eltern geschenkt bekommt
meine kennen wird mein waffeleisen ein
anderes waffeleisen um ein anderes
waffeleisen mein geschirrspüler habe ich
selbst angeschlossen
und jetzt gibt es ein bisschen viel korn
zu rechts macht euch gerade ja wann es
aber warum hast du so viele küchengeräte
also du hast die hälfte ja noch nie
benutzt doch in meinem kochbuch und ich
weiss ich nicke überall werden für mein
kochbuch rein aber dieses buch leute das
wird so lück und nicht nur
durchschnittlich lippen ein megabit
manche sind solidität und andere dafür
so wo das hat aber gehalten
und meine nachbarn hassen mich jetzt
schon
nein ich hoffe euch hat dieser
küchengeräte flex gefallen jetzt den
mega flex der megalithkultur afflecks
der mega litte ultra flex deluxe denn
ich zeige euch meine neuen kühl
viel spaß
[Musik]
ja hallo leute die solche fragen warum
zur hölle hat diese frau über sechs
löcher ben & jerry's in ihrem
kühlschrank das fragt ihr euch gerade
oder zum flexen weil ich war kein auto
ich habe keine coolen gadgets in meiner
wohnung aus an google+ der mir manchmal
musik spielt wisst ihr ja ich bin
richtig humble aber bei meinem
kühlschrank das ist kein spaß im
kühlschrank ist für mich das start na ja
das war schon immer ein traum von mir
ich wollte schon immer immer ich weiß
mit meinem vater habe ich schon damals
kühlschränke angeschaut mit eiswürfel
fach und ich stand da mit meinem vater
immer bei media markt und war so
irgendwann holen wir uns so ein
und dann hat mein vater vor zwei oder
drei oder so in der küche zwei
kühlschränke eingebaut also zwei normale
ohne eiswürfel und dann haben mir schon
gesagt
jetzt hab ich mir diesen kühlschrank
geholt und das erste was ich gemacht ist
man dazu sagen dass ich den traum lebe
ich habe als eiswürfel maker mit crushed
eis und kühlen wasser ja ich sag mal so
wenn das leben ein spiel wäre dann hätte
ich das jetzt auf jeden fall
durchgespielt denn ein kühlschrank mit
eiswürfel maker da kannst du mir mit
deinem m8 vorfahren da kannst du mir
dein iphone triple xx 19 8 zeigen nein
wenn über jemanden rein gehst und der
eine doppeltür kühlschrank hat mit
eiswürfeln sorry es geht nicht krass und
da so ein doppelter kühlschrank mit also
für mich gar nicht gerade günstig ist
kommt hier noch einmal werbung und habt
ihr euch schon dass sky entertainment
ticket geholt nein dann seid jetzt
schnell denn die bekommt den februar
gratis dazu also viel spaß beim serien
schauen die erste link in der
beschreibung
da kommt ihr zum angebot
sie ließ
gruselig und ungefähr drei jahren koch
videos auf youtube machen ist es das
erste mal dass ich meine küche richtig
zeige
und ich find's irgendwie total aufregend
und ich hoffe euch gefällt sie und das
mit dem flex ist natürlich auch ein
scherz also ich bin total dankbar dafür
was ich alles habe und was ich mir
leisten kann beziehungsweise wofür ich
jetzt einfach arbeiten muss und ich
hoffe euch hat gefallen
ich habe ja in den letzten drei jahren
war ich in 12
3 ich glaube in fünf verschiedenen
küchen oder vier oder so und ich hoffe
dass ich jetzt mal hier ein bisschen
länger bleiben kann
ich weiß nicht warum ich habe in berlin
so eine komische die wohn hier seit fünf
jahren und ich wohne jedes jahr in einer
anderen wohnung ich mache dazu glaube
ich auch unbedingt mal ein video weil
ich einfach mal erzählen will warum ich
ständig in der neuen wohnung bin weil
ich glaube viele von euch oder vielen
von euch ist es schon aufgefallen und
sie fragen mich dann immerhin sagen ja
es habe also warum also was ist da los
und ich kann mir auch vorstellen das ist
ziemlich komisch wirken kann und
deswegen kommt bald auf jeden fall mein
video dazu das video ist wieder in drei
cocktails die ballern und zwar die die
zehnte folge also nicht verpassen
ich hoffe dass euch das zuschauen spaß
gemacht habe schreibt mir gerne mal in
die kommentare was ihr so an
küchengeräten habt was ihm vielleicht
auch mal empfehlen könnt die einfach das
leben leichter machen oder auch einfach
witzig sind und spaß machen und zeigt
das video wenn es euch gefallen hat
abonniert den kanal wir sind schon
700.000 menschen um mein gott ist das
dass sie
keine ahnung sagt lukas es ist einfach
nur krass und ich meine das ist bescheid
und wir sehen uns beim nächsten mal eure
mal war die begrüßung die dogs am anfang
nicht deswegen liebsten ihr ziel zum
ende
bis dann tschüss